it's been a big year for Bitcoin the
virtual currency this is the currency
which only has value because people want
to use it they want to trade it so that
they can buy things online buy things
perhaps in private settings and so they
can hold on to it because they expect it
will gain value into the future it's a
currency that has been controversial
because one of its exchanges broke down
recently with the possible loss of
millions of dollars for people who
thought they had bitcoins that may have
been stolen but it's also been
controversial because of legal issues
how will certain entities allow it to be
traded will there be tracking of
bitcoins is it something that will
remain truly private in the future now
Bitcoin over the past year has seen a
lot of volatility in its value in part
because of some of these controversial
events and in part because there's been
more knowledge of Bitcoin and that has
spurred more demand that people want to
hold this thing as a currency or perhaps
as an investment and the fact is because
it's so volatile and because there's a
possibility that many other virtual
currencies will enter the market and
compete with Bitcoin you have to think
about it perhaps more like an investment
as well as a currency than you would
with something like dollars dollars yes
if you hold on to them they lose they
lose value relative to inflation as
prices go up but it's fairly stable and
you know that you'll be able to use
dollars in the future
Bitcoin is a little riskier because we
don't know exactly what the demand for
bitcoins will be in the future and
there's the possibility that we will run
out of new bitcoins they're supposed to
be a finite number out there if that
number is reached and no more bitcoins
are created then essentially individuals
will have the power to make monetary
policy for the entire Bitcoin market by
either hoarding bitcoins to contract the
money supply or pushing their bitcoins
out into the market to expand it now
this is something that we rarely see in
regular currency markets because
individuals don't have that much power
but it is something that could possibly
happen in the Bitcoin market in the
future now if you're considering buying
bitcoins I think the right way to think
about it is something like
investing in fine wines or expensive
musical instruments or paintings it's
something that you wouldn't want to do
unless you really knew a lot about what
was going on in that market and the
underlying value of these things and how
that it was created so I would say
Bitcoin can be a fun experiment it can
be something that you want to invest
time in as well as money but perhaps not
just for the dilettante especially
because there's so much uncertainty
surrounding its value in the future